um my name is eric benbow i'm an
associate professor
in the department of entomology and
osteopathic medical specialties at
michigan state university
and i'm also a fellow with the american
academy of forensic sciences
and so what i want to do today is
give you a little bit of background of
kind of how i got into it because
a lot of scientists research scientists
in academia who do forensics
have a background that wasn't directly
related to forensics at the beginning
and then i'm going to give you a little
introduction um
to to death and decomposition the
necrobiome
and then some past and current research
related to the postmortem microbiome
and then one specific case study but
some research case studies as well
and then what are the challenges and
outlooks on how where
we want to use the postmortem microbiome
in forensics
the research in my lab centers on how
insects and microbes
interact in this the triangular fashion
within aquatics
disease and carrying systems and we
address
questions related to the ecology and
evolution of these relationships
and then how they can be applied and
over the last couple of years
i was originally trained in aquatic
entomology
but did a postdoc with someone who did
forensic entomology
and that got me interested into some
basic questions of when something dies
um some kind of vertebrae animal
what happens to it and what are the
organisms involved with that death and
how can we use um
that information for applications and
forensics and so it started
with insects but along the way and i'm
going to talk a little bit about this
we figured out that the microbes
associated with
something uh decomposing could
potentially be used
in forensic investigations and several
other research groups were doing the
same thing
developing a microbial clock if you will
using
entire microbial communities in
um in their ability to determine how
long someone's been dead
perhaps where they've been maybe how
they've died or in aquatic circumstances
how long the body's been submerged and
so we're going to talk a little bit
about the background of that
and then some research and then some
future challenges for those of you
who may be sensitive to dead
photos of dead animals or humans
i have not put a lot of those into this
presentation but there are a few
and you may want to either avert your
eyes or
leave the session um
death unfortunately
everything will end up dying and humans
in particular
have expressed the fascination with that
in many ways and
if you go to the louvre in paris you can
find
lots of different artworks related to uh
the human perception of death and
perhaps what
is going on in the afterlife and that's
just been part of our history if you
look at ancient egyptians and how they
preserved their dead and mummified
there's been this interest in
what happens to humans postmortem
in another artwork the the macabre of
understanding
um the leftover and the remains
of something that was once living is
profound
and ubiquitous throughout art and
throughout history of course
and many of us ponder our own
mortality i certainly do but
many others in forensics and researchers
with regard to carrion
and death i often think about how we can
understand
the process the post-mortem processes
natural processes
for utility in something like the
justice system
and in many ways we're finding for
understanding public health
and doing public health surveillance
using the dead
so that they can inform the living
and a few years ago our work our
collaborative
work was highlighted in the new york
times magazine
where the author was quite interested in
the microbes
you know the microscopic microscopic
organisms
associated with their bodies but you'll
see in the hourglass there's
renditions cartoon renditions of
bacteria but also those yellow
images are maggots or larvae from flies
and what we were discussing is how we
can use both
microbes and insects to determine
how long someone's been dead or perhaps
how long someone's been submerged in
water
or someone's body in this case and part
of that was
describing the collective uh
community of organisms that recycle that
have evolved to recycle
decomposing or dead vertebrate organisms
and
um and not just vertebrate organisms
that's for forensics but
anything that has been once living has
biomass that
is recycled back into nature and so i
draw this red line around this box this
is necro mass that's any form of organic
matter
that was once living and now is being
recycled and there's a separate page
community
that physically degrades that but a
focus for this presentation is the
external
and internal microbial communities or
the microbiomes
of that necromass and then the substrate
upon which that necromancer is laying
where the body's laying or in the water
body
there's also a microbial communities
that colonize
that organic matter and so what we've
been interested in
is understanding these processes and
then potentially how
to develop new tools that can be used in
forensic investigations
so let me give you a little photo
montage
related to a publication that we had
this is
an easter gray kangaroo these blowflies
these adult blowflies that you see
are both eating a little bit but also
mating
and then they're oval positing meaning
they're laying eggs on a carcass
and this happens within minutes
sometimes hours sometimes days
even with human bodies and
lots of many researchers have used
insects as evidence
to determine how long something's been
dead and i'll talk a little bit more
about that
and so they are the main players for
this presentation
related of the necrobiome
that interact with microbes in a way
that we think can be used
in forensic investigations
some of the work in research related to
understanding microbe insect
interactions on purposes goes from
aquatic organisms such as
pacific salmon where they spend most of
their life in the ocean and migrate into
the rivers and streams
spawn and then have mass death lots of
research has gone into the natural
history of these processes and we've
learned a lot about how
microbes and insects interact during the
decomposition of salmon
the blue flies themselves lay these eggs
look like little
pieces of rice those eggs hatch within a
few hours
within about a day sometimes less
depending on the temperature
and then they start consuming that
carcass and so they play a major role
in how the microbes may affect their
attraction but also
how the insects may affect the microbial
communities of that
dead body other sources of necromancers
like dung
and dung beetles dung beetles have
evolved
intricate relationships with dung
recycling the dawn
breeding on the dome and raising their
offspring
on the dome as well and so we've learned
a lot about decomposition
with those types of studies in aquatic
systems there aren't
very many insects or other invertebrates
that have evolved
to consume the carcass itself
but in this case these catastros are
consuming the microbial biofilm
on the carcass itself and you can see
the white patches where the kettle
spices scrape that microbial biofilm off
and i'll show later in a case study
where that biofilm growth on a body
might be used to determine how long that
body's been submerged
for instance we could probably with more
research determine how long
this salmon has been sitting at the
bottom of this stream
just based on the community composition
and diversity
of the microbial communities in that
biofilm
and then there's vertebra scavengers
that usually get the the most pressed
with
carrion ecology because they certainly
modify
the carcass itself but they also modify
how the insects
colonize the carcass and the microbial
communities
within it as well but in general
everything once living dies that organic
matter that was once living
becomes recycled into nature whether
that's a log
a millipede leaf litter or
a vertical carcass as indeed a kangaroo
in australia
and we're focused on those vertebrate
carcasses because
they resemble they they uh act as
surrogates
for how we understand human
decomposition and the
biological interactions that occur
during that time
but you can also see in an art and in
the 13th century
this um japanese art form of
portraying sequential decay of a cadaver
in quite interesting detail again this
is the necrobiome of the community
of organisms that have evolved to
consume
and ultimately recycle a human body
and so it's here where we want to
understand the basic biological
mechanisms and ecological mechanisms
of the necrobiome to determine the time
of death of the postmodern mineral
as i said i got my start in forensic
entomology and there's an entomological
clock that we use so in day one
the adult flies come in lay their eggs
the eggs hatch into early instar larvae
after three to seven days they're a
little bit bigger
and then they begin to pupate after
about eight or nine days
this clock though is temperature
dependent meaning
it happens faster if it's hot and slower
if it's cold
and but either way if you if you collect
the maggot
from a body and you know the species and
you know its size
you can often back calculate if you know
the temperature
on how long those flies
larvae have been on the body and that
has been used in the court of law
hundreds of times
part of our research was understanding
the variability in those insects and how
they colonized and how quickly they
colonized
in this particular study we saw we put
out six wine carcasses
and note the variability just between
carcass a
and carcass b how much insect activity
is on b
but not on a and so we were curious what
leads to this variability
in insect activity and through several
experiments in published papers we found
it's the microbial communities that the
suite of organisms from
prokaryotes to bacteria to protozoans
to microscopic worms and fungi
that interact in meaningful ways
to recycle the body and we wanted to
determine if we could figure out
signatures or profiles of these
microbial communities
that could act as a clock like the
entomological clock but using microbial
succession
communities well at the same time
huge papers were coming out on the
medical importance of microbes
through the human microbiome project
earth microbiome project
um additional papers came out first
saying that microbes
outnumbered human cells 10 to 1 that was
later
adjusted to be one-to-one nevertheless
microbes make up a huge part of the
human body
other research and other groups have
started looking at this whether it's the
microbiology of the build environment
cardiology interdisciplinary microbiome
projects
etc microbes are interacting with living
humans
can we use those microbes for
understanding that that
part of the microbiome project is
understanding how symbioses
and maybe even non-symbiotes affect how
an organism like ourselves interacts and
is modified in the environment because
we know microbiota modulate
or it can be modulated to antibiotics
probiotics prebiotics
there's a genetic background for each of
us in our diet and state
that affects the microbiota of us
um given this variability can we still
understand these communities in a way
that can be useful for forensics
because we are each made up of billions
of these microbes in our system
well there have been a slew of papers
that have
been published over the last 10 years
related to this usually
using surrogate animals but if they're
not using syrian animals they've been
using human
human remains usually through human
donors and anthropological research
facilities
amazing work has come from these
including
just a netcast work using
human remains a couple of different
facilities
in determining a microbial clock
others have used human remains
usually uh four to seven of them
um in in these anthropological
facilities where they monitor the
communities the microbial communities
over time some of our work uh
however has led to us collaborating with
a medical examiner
in michigan where we're doing larger
scale surveys
of
human cases death cases during routine
autopsy death investigation
both types of studies provide keen
insight
into how human remains decompose and how
the microbial communities change
but what's unique to forensics and what
we found
working with that medical examiner is
there's unique cases of for instance
two children that were frozen for
multiple years
and that gets into some of the
challenges associated with
using information directly using
information for direct for case work
a body's placed in plastic
and buried for two years
the microbial communities have a
cadaver that's laid on the ground for
years are going to be quite different
than that
placed the you know on the body placed
in plastic and buried
and so we're keen to understand the
variability
in not only human microbiomes
how it varies across space and time but
also related to circumstances and manner
and cause of death
because we think there's still
signatures that are useful but we need
enough research to identify those
signatures
there's been many other studies in the
past several years
uh here in this table that you can see
look at the total number of subjects
most of those that are between 2 and
20 are at anthropological research
facilities the ones with 28 46 188
are have been those that have have used
cases during death investigation
but let me give you a little bit of a
background on how we understand and
develop that microbial clock and i'm
going to do that with
a study from a master's student of mine
courtney weatherby
where she exposed six
swine carcasses over the course of a
full
length of decomposition from fresh
remains to what you see on the very
right hand side um the bones and
skin and some dry tissue
and what i want to know here is when you
first see my
insect communities is about 15 57
accumulated degree hours adh
that's when the major insect activity
was evident
that's going to become important because
what we did was swab these
carcasses over time as long as there
were skin available
we then analyzed the microbial
communities over time on the carcass
but we also swabbed the maggot masses
those large magnet masses that you see
at 1845 and 2469.
we got the secretions and excretions of
the maggots themselves
and looked at that microbiome and then
we would sample some of those insects
and look at the internal microbiome of
those insects as they grew on the
carcass over time
because the hypothesis was that any
dead organisms has its own microbiome
but the
flies that are attracted to naturally
involved
attraction too the carcass carry their
own microbes
and when they open posit or they lay
those eggs
and investigate the carcass like i
should with that kangaroo
they deposit their own microbial
communities
and that certainly has an effect and
there's been published papers
um on this it has an effect on how the
communities
the microbial communities change on the
dead body
and so we wanted to investigate how
those microbes change
and in the meantime that also allows us
to develop
a microbial clock on this so that's how
we suggest that as the larvae grow and
develop they then acquire those microbes
that were once part of the cadaver but
also
part of what the adult flies brought
into the system
so this looks like a complicated slide
on the x-axis
is accumulated degree hours essentially
that's time
that has been adjusted for temperature
variability among those six
swine carcasses and then on the y-axis
you see the mean phyllo relative
abundance so this is
these are entire phylums bylaw
of bacteria and
if you look at right before
the insects became evident on the
carcasses
and so that's the top part and if you
look at the skin microbiome what you see
is proteobacteria pretty low
early on but right when the insects
colonize
they start to jump higher vermicutes are
high
and then go lower once the insects are
there so if you're doing a microbial
clock without accounting for
insect evidence you might have some
variability that you can't explain
so once the insects were there we
started monitoring with the dashed lines
the maggot mass community so that's just
when we put a swab into the mask and got
the excretions and secretions
that's the small line and you can see
produce bacteria still remain high
from acoustic lower if you then look at
the larvae in the internal microbiome of
the larvae
the large batter dash lines you can see
that the pretty bacteria continue
to increase as the larvae increased in
size as well
and at 2469 you can see
that there was nothing remained of skin
that we could use
to that we could swap for the skin
communities so effectively that carcass
has gone from
a swine to essentially
a large population of insects
in their excretions and secretions
um that is part of developing this
microbial clock where you take
sequential
samples as a carcass or human cadaver
decomposes over time but in real life
death investigations you only get one
time to sample this
sample the the case um and so it's
important to understand how much
variability there is not only on a body
but among bodies or cases within certain
populations of
humans so we published this a couple of
years ago
in terms of validating that um research
microbial clock of sequential samples
over time
because we could only sample them once
during the death investigation so her
questions were
what is the post-mortem microbial
diversity how does body side sex
age remain or death affect the estimated
post-mortem
post-mortem interval and does the living
environment
influence the microbiota so we worked
with the medical examiner dr carl
schmidt
with wayne county in detroit uh
with his cases and his crew would
collect swab samples from the eyes
ears nose mouth umbilicus and rectum
those were stored at negative 20 and
until we were able to
um analyze them
the metadata there's a slew of metadata
that we
recorded as part of the study and then
we were able to statistically evaluate
and control
for many of these covariates and to turn
to identify
the microbial communities of importance
the swab went through a standard
pipeline that most of the
labs doing this kind of work used um we
extract dna had it sequenced
we're using 16 srna using my seek
we used to analyze it and then r for
data visualization
visualization and statistics
well we had 188 cases lots of very uh
range what you do should note is most of
our cases were less than 49 hours
but were pretty equal on females and
males
black and white and a variety of
manners and causes of death these were
evaluated
statistically to associate their
variation
what we got was body area makes a huge
difference
in the microbial communities so if
you're not familiar with an ordination
and that's what this is
the closer the points are the more
similar the microbial the collective
microbial communities are
so rectum um or coordinates and clusters
together pretty tightly although there
is some variability spread throughout
those red points
the mouth also clusters down lower on
the
pcoa2 axis
the ears also cluster and this is
significant clustering meaning the
communities of the
rectum mouth and ears are significantly
different from each other
note that the eyes and nose which are
part of the face
right with the ears and mouth are all
part of the same system
um and so they're spread throughout and
don't cluster as much and so there's
overlap in the microbial communities the
body site has
an important effect and so looking at
body site
for your microbial clock or your
microbial metric
of interest was very important and so
that's what we did
to kind of summarize what you're seeing
here several bar graphs
looking at the mean 16s residual rna
diversity meaning
the number of species if you will and so
that you get
higher diversity at less with cases less
than 48 hours
post mortal and lower diversity
after 49 hours postmortem
and so this was consistent in the eyes
ears nose and mouth but not in the
rectum
so this is an important finding right if
you're going to use microbial
communities in death investigation you
need to know where to sample
the rectum for this particular question
is not effective
not only was diversity different between
uh 48 less than 48 and greater than 49
post-mortem intervals but the entire
communities were
a specific microbial taxa it could be
used to predict
those categories of post-mortem mineral
i won't get into the details of those
but you're welcome to to read the paper
and scientific reports
and lastly i'm going to conclude with a
case study
when the postmortem microbiome probably
would have helped
um this was featured on the oxygen
channel as part of the smiley face
killers
i have no opinion about the smiley
killers hypothesis
but we were asked to run an experiment
because of a suspicious case as part of
that series
of type guy um
and and to summarize what the case was
and why it was suspicious
is um todd went to a out to a party
one evening in 2008 i believe in 2007.
he was walking home allegedly speaking
to his girlfriend
and abruptly the phone went dead
no one had heard from him or seen him
for 21 days where his body was pulled
from a small lake in michigan
and upon uh evaluation uh there was no
there's antidepressant growth in his
toxicology reports
interviews with his parents and friends
suggested that he was not
on any kind of you know depressants or
antidepressants and he wasn't depressed
and so um being gone for his body being
gone for 21 days
was suspicious because of the way the
body looked upon recovery
and this was noted in the autopsy report
and in photographs
where there wasn't a lot of
decomposition of the body that
was floating in or submerged
in a small lake for 21 days in the
middle of summer
and so what we did was we ran an
experiment with three pig carcasses in a
small
lake in michigan and we swabbed several
places on
each one of the carcasses and we
evaluated how the external microbial
communities
changed on those carcasses over about a
four week period
and what we were interested in was these
two extremes meaning
early floating in red versus advanced
floating decay in blue because we
found that our carcasses were more in
line of
advanced floating decay condition
um than something that was much early
floating
meaning were the microbial communities
on our carcasses
um early floating could we identify
microbial communities that were early
floating versus those that were
advanced decay and what you can see real
similar to our previous study in detroit
um in the box and whisker graphs on the
left
those are metrics of diversity so you
get higher diversity of the microbial
communities on the carcasses
in early floating the red and much
less diversity in the floating decay
green or the advanced clothing to be in
blue
and that's pretty consistent along
different metrics suggesting the
diversity
significantly drops as
decomposition or submergence progresses
over the summer over four weeks of
summer and if you look at that
ordination again what you see is early
floating clusters out
independent of the others and this is
highly significant whereas
the green and the blue the advanced
stages of decomposition
are clustered a little bit together but
also separate
now if the body
was really in or was in the water for 21
days
at the time of discovery it would have
taken
microbial swabs we may have been able to
differentiate the microbial communities
of 21 days
compared to the microbial communities of
early floating meaning three to five
days
of submergence that's what our data
suggests that
in the future work if a body's found
let's swab the body let's also take
samples of the microbial communities
of the habitat and determine
if they match a high or low diversity
community
that might be representative of an early
floating
stage versus an advanced loading now
lots of questions remain with this case
this was just
one experiment in one part of michigan
and the results are not generalizable
but it shows promise on how
understanding microbial communities and
how they change over time
could potentially be used in future
death investigations
so the summary of this presentation the
necrobiome provides
um interesting ecological and
evolutionary underpinnings that we might
be able to use
for forensic application
both in studies anthropological
facilities and with our larger
case studies with real death
investigations
we can predict pmi with reasonable
accuracy
many of those studies are at patrol
facilities which are less realistic
but offered sequential um sampling over
time
uh the large scale studies suggest
there's variability but we can at least
determine
the 448 and after 49 hours which
can be critical in a death investigation
so we think there's excellent potential
for both post-mortem microbes in most
cases what are those challenges we need
more confirmation of validation
both among studies and within studies
there's
a lot of variability across cities
regions and countries
how much variability is that and does it
affect the tools and standard operating
procedures
we'd like to put in place
future protocols will be need to be
relatively quick
easy and inexpensive because
in addition there's few opportunities to
collaborate with medical examiner
offices
and those offices are incredibly busy
and those investigations
are incredibly busy and they have a lot
to do and so
they often suffer from tight budgets and
crunch
time and so our future protocols have to
be
quick easy and inexpensive
other challenges really how much how
much does the anti-mortal health
condition impact the post-mortem
microbiome our early studies have
suggested that the anti-moral
health condition does affect the
post-mortem microbiome
but we need additional studies to
validate
and test that how does outdoor
circumstances affect
the variation how do indoor
circumstances how does burial affect
pmi in microbiomes so we need to track
cases archive
data retrieval and develop a database
which
my collaborators and i have done um
here's the website for our human
postmortem microgrant database if you're
interested
we're always interested in uh
collaborations
it's the largest ongoing data collection
for the postmortem microbiome
associated with determining manner and
cause of death and post-mortem intervals
we have almost 15 600 plus individual
samples
over 2000 cases representing all kinds
of manners and causes of death
and it samples a population that's
typically not sampled in
microbiome studies where you get
volunteers that are
either healthy or have some kind of
ailment to understand
public consequences i'd like to end with
my
um very uh tight team of collaborators
uh dr jennifer peckhall dr carl schmidt
and heather jordan um at various
institutions
and some previous funding from the
national institute of justice that
allowed us
to explore the variability in postmodern
microbiome
among autopsy cases so i thank you for
your attention
and i look forward to answering many of
your questions